I think morality is sentimental you know
it's about how we feel about what's
happened rather than some sort of
calculus based on logical principles do
you think it's based on how we feel like
what exactly do you mean by that sure
like for
example a Libertarian will say the state
infringing on my right to bear arms is
immoral and therefore I am rationally
justified in this but the damn straight
yeah no no I and I agree with because
I'm an Englishman but the underlying
thing under that is a kind of moral
Prejudice do you identify as a
conservative I I guess I would call
myself a traditionalist rather than a
conservative I feel like I've gone with
libertarian since I was like 14 well I
mean libertarian is an ideological
Viewpoint you're telling me I'm stuck in
an ideology if I identify as a
Libertarian it's an ideological position
the problem I have with the ideology
really is that it gives people a false
sense of moral superiority it's not just
in the intent it's actually in the thing
you do and the consequences you bring
about as well well I'm not going to be
able to say a Libertarian after this
podcast so you've taken that there's a
definite external place that people
regard more highly than the people
themselves we use the terms objective
all the time and Universal but like what
does that even mean like what does
objective mean it means from the
perspective of the universe that's such
a weird thing to aspirety do you think
this has anything to do with the lack of
religion right now it would be the view
of kind of the good of humanity you
[Music]
know
Carl Benjamin welcome to my podcast
thanks so much for having me yeah it's
nice to finally meet you I feel like
I've heard of you I've been following
you on Twitter forever my friends have
had you on their podcasts and we haven't
spoken before so this should be fun yeah
I saw your Oxford Union Address
actually the meat one thank you yeah
yeah I'm constantly in a battle against
the vegans meets good we should eat it I
think I think I technically lost that
like they do a vote at the end and I
think I lost but there's a bit of
confusion about people which door you
exit to vote so I think I that though I
I don't really care what the popular
consensus on a subject is I'll for
myself whether I think is correct or not
oh you don't come off as that type of
person at all oh really oh no no I'm
being sarcastic you definitely
definitely
do good
so how did were you always like a more
okay do you identify as a
conservative yeah I think conservative
is
um excuse me a fairly I mean it's quite
a broad label it's not very very deep um
but it's good enough I I guess I would
call myself a traditionalist rather than
a conservative but the they overlap
quite significantly so that's
fine okay what what's a traditionalist
versus a conservative
well a conservative is someone who
is always chasing the last Paradigm
whereas a traditionalist is someone who
is constantly moving forward in their
own Paradigm uh in the Paradigm that
we've inherited from the past living in
the present and then inevitably move
forward in into the future and I guess
you could just oppose this against um
any kind of ideologist who has an
abstract a priori view of what the world
should look like and they're constantly
trying to interpose that onto reality
and reformat reality to make that fit
this predefined
Vision okay that seems to make sense I
feel like I've gone with libertarian
since I was like 14 even though I
probably only have a vague understanding
what a Libertarian is but I didn't
identify as a conservative it's like I
don't think I'm that I don't really like
anybody whatever like whatever Viewpoint
not agreeing with anyone you know unless
I think it's right is I suppose
everybody thinks that way well I mean
libertarian's an ideological Viewpoint
so you've got um a sort you're telling
me I'm stuck in an ideology if I
identify as a
Libertarian hey guys I hope you're
enjoying this episode I certainly did
just dropping in to suggest a sauna
blanket as an excellent Christmas gift
for your loved ones or yourself Bond
Chargers infrared sauna blanket is my
go-to portable sauna blanket again we're
exposed to so many toxins daily I don't
think people take that as seriously as
they should I wish this was touched on
more because I think it's what's behind
my autoimmunity and food sensitivities
and my parents illnesses environmental
exposures and saunas are one of the
things you can do to help your body
detox faster among other things these
sauna blankets work just like a big
sauna but they're portable easy to clean
easy to store they ship worldwide and if
it doesn't meet your expectations for
some reason or maybe you're just whiny
and you don't want to sweat their easy
return policies has you covered with a
30-day trial and a solid 12month
warranty you can go to bond charge.com
that's b n c h r g.com MP and use code
MP to save 15% off it's linked in the
comments so consider it as a healthy
Christmas gift enjoy the rest of this
episode well it's an ideological
position isn't it like it's I mean you
know a lot of people do have ideologies
and it's not necessarily that ideologies
are always bad I guess the the question
is really whether you let reality get
overridden by the ideology or you
override reality with the ideology and
we the the problems with the problem I
have with the ideology really is that it
gives people a false sense of moral
superiority and they say well I adhere
to a particular ideology and therefore I
am a good person regardless really of
what I've done or what I will do because
I hold a certain set of beliefs and I
just don't really believe that morality
works that way I don't really believe
that being a good person works that way
I actually think
it's not just in the intent that
morality is located it's actually in the
thing you do and the consequences you
bring about as well are all part of the
moral scheme and so you can believe a
good thing do a good thing and end up
with a negative consequence and you
might not be a bad person in the
immediate sense but if you keep doing
that thing and you know you're going to
get the negative consequence then it
becomes a kind of form of vanity where
you're like well I'm just doing it for
me now even though I'm bringing about
all these negative consequences and then
conversely if you had a person who was
like an incompetent super villain and
they're like right I'm going to kill
everyone in this city and actually they
tried to poison the well and it gave
everyone really clean teeth or something
you know like you wouldn't say oh that's
a good person because they helped
everyone no they were trying to hurt
them you know so I I think the morality
is in all of these spaces it's not just
in one place so this really is the
problem I have with ideology and also it
doesn't really track to reality I mean
there's there's a genuine question at
the moment of whether we want free
markets or whether we want property
ownership like free markets are an
ideological abstraction but property
ownership is something real and concrete
but at the moment free markets are
actually inhibiting property ownership
because of the free movement of peoples
and so in Britain for example we get a
million new people in a year you can
imagine what that's done to the house
prices in this country and so actually
getting on the property ladder is
becoming just utterly imposs possible
for regular young people and so free
markets are actually damaging people's
ability to own property and yet this is
the ideological abstraction we find
ourselves committed
to and I actually want to question those
things and not being ideological means
that I can and I also still have a kind
of framework of where I want to be from
where I already am considering where
we've just been you know yeah okay that
makes sense I think I I had an issue
until recently and I don't know if I've
gotten more disagreeable I got older or
just less naive from being screwed over
by people and just learning what they're
like but I I I'd always track back and
go oh this person did this bad thing but
look at how they were thinking that
brought them up to that moment like that
doesn't make them a bad person they just
made a mistake but then you get these
people and they'll just make mistakes
and hurt more and more and more people
and I suppose then you end up in like
you know worst case scenario that's a
Hitler position as he thought he was
doing St he thought he was doing
something good he most certainly wasn't
so like you were talking about intent
behind actions not you know being a a
marker for Morality which I think is
completely accurate doesn't really
matter how you got where you are but if
you're doing something bad then that
should speak for itself that makes sense
yeah I think so and like when when when
you when you take this kind of a
three-dimensional view of what morality
is you realize just how shallow the
modern discourse is
right like you look you I'm we're we're
Libertarians we're socialists and
they're constantly arguing from these
very abstract positions where they
ascribe to themselves all perfect
goodness and light and so obviously
anyone who disagrees on that must be a
bad person or really stupid and actually
it could just be that maybe they don't
describe all of what morality is and
things are really complex and really we
need to get out of the abstract spaces
and get into the real world and actually
look at what's going on and I I don't
think morality rational that's the thing
because the the problem of the ideology
is entirely rational I think morality is
sentimental you know it's about how we
feel about what's happened really rather
than some sort of calculus based on
logical principles I don't I don't
really think morality works that
way you think it's based on how we feel
yeah okay
sentiment so okay can you do yeah
describe that a little bit so if you
care about something happen like what
exactly do you mean by that for example
um a Libertarian will say okay the state
infringing on my right to bear arms is
immoral and therefore um I am rationally
justified in this or I have a particular
rational justification for how I believe
but the the
underlying yeah no no I and I agree with
that right because I'm an Englishman but
the underlying thing under that really
is a kind of just moral Prejudice so I
feel that's correct and the people who
want to take away weapons are those
people who feel that really and they'll
come up with rational justification but
the underneath that is really just a
kind of personal prejudice against you
being able to defend yourself because
they believe something crazy um as you
can see I'm a lot more sympathetic to
the libertarian side of any argument
than I am the Socialist side um but
really it it's how to describe like kind
of strings I guess that connect each
other
together and morality is kind of found
in that connection between two people
and that's a Sentimental Bond so like
when you get people who are like say oh
I'm abstractly sort of I Jesse petson
has this question he's like do you love
black people he like what does that mean
like what does that mean black people as
a class you know some sort of abstract
gal entity you know like what does that
mean I don't love white people I don't
love black people I do
this person and I do love that person I
love this place that I've been to you
know like it's it's not it's not a a
rational construct it's a heartfelt
emotion that you feel in your chest that
I think is the real root of morality and
that's what we struggle with every day
and I think that the modern way of
describing the world has become entirely
rationis because I I what I love doing
is reading books from like a hundred
years ago because they just talk in a
different way to the way we talk now and
they talk about about things in a much
more rich and in many way sort of
judgmental way but you can tell they
really love the things that they're
talking about whereas we seem a lot more
shallow and a lot more disconnected from
things and I don't I'm not even sure
I've got the proper language to describe
what I'm trying to put across here you
know but there's there's definitely
something Hollow about the lives we're
leading now compared to the way people
experienced the world in the pre-20th
century era I wonder if it's too much
yes I agree and you can definitely pick
that up in in older books uh do you
think that's just from like how much of
that is from over stimulation from just
being exposed to so many things at the
same time doesn't that make you care
less
almost maybe um there's just so much
going
on I think there was always quite a lot
going on in the past though and often it
was way worse than what's going on now
um I mean you know
100 years ago we were losing 50,000 men
a day in trenches you know and the
entire nations were heaving at war with
one another across the world for five
years at a time so I don't know if it's
that things
are there's less or more going on
necessarily we're definitely more
immediately
stimulated but I I kind of feel this is
a consequence of what's happened rather
than the source of the problem I there
seems to me something wrong with the way
we use science and I'm I'm not the only
person to have thought this like CS
Lewis and Julius saola both came to the
same conclusion whereas like science
that the Locust of science is outside of
humanity uh and so science is being done
for its own sake rather than for the
sake of mankind and actually I think
that we should put ourselves as the
primary good here when we're doing
science and when science is outside of
us as the primary good it's I mean for
example social media what was the who
was the co-founder of social media
Facebook who was like look we knew this
was addictive and we did it anyway well
then you're not doing that for the good
of the people using it because I mean
social media sounds like a great idea
hey you can easily contact your friends
okay we need to do it for our own good
not for the good of the platform getting
clicks to make money for advertisers and
things like that that's a that's an
external goal to the goal of actually
making something good for us to use in
the world and so a lot of science is
like this and so I'm just and I'm not
trying to just throw science entirely
under the bus or something but like
there's there's a
definite
external place that people regard more
highly than the people themselves and
I'm really concerned about that like we
we use the terms objective all the time
and Universal but like what that even
mean like what does objective mean it
means from the perspective of the
universe like a perspective of non on
mankind like the universe as as a as a
giant entire conceptual entity looks at
something and is supposed to make a
judgment it's like that's such a weird
thing to Aspire to like can't we just
use human judgments we are humans you
know it's it should be okay for us to
make our human judgments from the
perspective of our own two eyes looking
at something as human beings so I know
I'm going on but like this has really
got me on the tangent um but I I just
there's something wrong with the way
we're conceiving of the world and we're
trying to put it right
there's something wrong with that do you
think that this could just be kind this
could be okay so how do I describe this
without sounding like a do you
think this has anything to do with a
lack of religion right now or lack of
kind of judeo-christian beliefs as a
foundation of
society because that would put you
outside
of not not science like that's a not
exactly what I mean but it would be the
view of kind of the good of Humanity you
know as as opposed to looking things
looking at things through this
subjective scientific
lens so I've wondered this
because I wonder so if you go back 200
years that in in philosophical circles
they they're questioning or no 300 years
uh they're questioning whether the idea
of a Mechanical Universe a self-
sustaining universe that doesn't require
God to be a part of the universe and a
sort of prime mover in the universe will
eventually destroy faith in God and um
this was proposed by John Lock and it
was refuted by a chap called Berkeley he
said no look you're going to create a a
world full of atheists if they don't
believe God is the underpinning force of
the universe and John Lock who himself
was obviously a deeply religious man and
wanted atheism outward essentially just
denied this and said no no that's not
going to happen well actually he was
wrong that has happened like you look
around especially in my country almost
everyone is either some version of
agnostic atheist or nominally Christian
but never goes to church the church
tenden here is like 6% uh it's really
low so in our sort of revealed religion
we're atheists uh and so I don't know
whether you know it's a consequence of
that but I wouldn't be surprised if that
turned out to be the case it would not
surprise me and the thing is I've
struggled with this I've got I've got
Christian like look you could just
become a Christian like no I could kind
of hard yeah you can't just like
suddenly become one exactly I I was
raised in what is essentially a sort of
irreligious society and so I was I've
been trying to explain them look I
actually feel like
maybe maybe it's a kind of disability or
something I just don't have the thing
required to do the thing that you're
asking me to do but um yeah I don't know
I don't know I I had
pretty big shift um so two years ago I
grew up in a totally like either atheist
or agnostic Society too in Toronto I
didn't know anyone I knew one person
whose family went to church and then he
was always complaining oh I have to go
to church and then he stopped going to
church and that was the only and I was
like oh the weirdos that go to church
that was like and and then I had my dad
and he told me oh there's like
importance in these
stories but I mean it's hard to
understand that when you're like 10 um
and then and then a couple of years I
had some weird I just had too many weird
miraculous experiences where I finally
like clicked in and so now I believe in
God which is something that I had always
been like maybe I don't know what's out
there like maybe it's a thing but I
never got it and my mom converted to
Catholicism and I was like that seems to
be working for you but I don't get it um
I don't feel it and I feel like from
meeting Christians specific
Christians the way they look at the
world is definitely significantly
different than how I grew up like I I
grew up looking at it through a
scientific objective lens and it was
pretty depressing I would say this kind
of harsh but it's not something you can
just click on oh believe this yeah like
how how are you supposed to believe that
no I'm I'm totally with you
like for for me I was never I never felt
like I lacked religion there was
nothing there was no like whole there
for me I was just being a happy normal
person my whole life you know I've
always been pretty optimistic um but
I've never not believed in a sort of
Mechanical Universe because it seems to
be true to me I
I but there are there are definitely
unanswered questions and but the the
point I think you're making is totally
true whatever it is I'm supposed to feel
I just don't and I don't want to be
unauthentic about that but conversely I
am very sympathetic to the Christians um
I mean there a every Christian of Met
has been a lovely person right really
good really decent that's always weird
yeah yeah so and so I look back at the
new atheists I think why are you
attacking these people you know aren't
there worst people on Earth to attack
them these people um and then you know
Christianity is the tradition of the
West right it's it's definitely the
moral Bedrock upon which our societies
are based and again this is another
place where the new atheists were just
wrong
really you know the enlightenment the
second or rational world wasn't
something independent of Christianity it
was made by Christians um and so there's
I don't see why we would deny that as
it's so self-evidently true if we just
know anything about the history of the
evolution of our philosophies so that's
another thing okay well you know we why
can't we give Christianity it's just due
here in improving the world and I I
there's nothing repugnant about
Christian doctrine to me either right
that you know I'm not I don't want to be
like well Jesus was a great moral
teacher I mean
obviously that's not really as an asine
thing to say but there's nothing
repugnant about the religion so I don't
feel the need to attack it I can think
of far more repugnant religions to
attack uh if I felt inclined so it it's
I don't understand why we ar more
sympathetic to the Christians but the
Christians are the ones who just get
ignored if not persecuted I mean in my
country they're actively being
persecuted by the state for example if
you're a Christian woman and you go and
pray silently in your own head outside
an abortion clinic you get arrested for
having a thought crime so it's and if if
you're if you're a Christian Street
Preacher you get arrested for spreading
hate speech so oh yeah that doesn't
happen to the Islamic
preachers so it's it's just remarkable
that's interesting
yeah that's weird so if you have two
people people that are I remember there
was this guy in downtown Toronto that
used to walk downtown and every time you
passed him he he'd he'd yell Jesus and
so you'd pass him he like like this guy
yelling Jesus at you so those PE those
people
uh if they're of like is Islam faith in
the UK that's okay but it's not okay if
they're Christians I haven't heard this
I've never seen an example of an Islamic
preacher on the streets being okay uh
you know having any kind of negative
contact with the police but I've seen it
multiple times where a Christian
preacher and often they'll be from
Africa uh so it's not even you know
they're not even needed people but
they'll still be arrested because it's
Christian doctrine that they're
promoting it's just very strange like
why would why would the British State
operate in such a
way yeah that's weird so how has in the
last five years how have you seen like
where where in the UK are you
approximately I'm in the southwest okay
and have you seen that area change in
the last five
years yeah it's um it's been tragic so
in in Britain we're a very small country
um with a very high population very high
population density particularly in
England and we for some reason for the
last 13 years have had a conservative
government that has just allowed
increasing numbers of people from
anywhere in the world to come and live
here and that has noticeably damaged not
only the fabric of society but the
institutions of society and it's driving
the country off of a cliff because a lot
of our infrastructure was built 50 years
ago for a population of about 45 to 50
million and we now have official figures
put at 69 million but the thing is there
are going to be million and heagles also
here so it's probably somewhere north of
70 up to about 75 um in 2011 one of the
supermarkets came out and said we're
selling enough food for 80 million
people and uh everyone say can't be
right um but it might not be so terribly
wrong uh because I mean you know they
are feeding people they should know but
the the the thing that that's done has
made everything worse it's just it's
just a sheer number of people so the
roads are always packed the roads are in
terrible condition everything costs way
more than it ought healthc care is a
black hole so every year I mean it's
just mathematically inevitable if every
year you bring in a million people and
say 1% of those didn't need to use the
healthc care system which is going to be
way more than that but let's get
charitably 1% well that's 1% that's not
being paid for so that's an extra
however many percentage out of the
budget for the National Health Service
that has to come on the shoulders of the
people already here and then you think
okay well they'll get jobs well let's
assume they all got jobs next year
you've got another million people and a
percentage of those and so it's
inevitable that the costs will continue
to spiral and this is just destroying
the NHS but it's terrible for the
doctors and the nurses because they're
run ragged the NHS has got like a
horrific staff turnover rate where
obviously people don't want to work
there as a doctor or nurse they move
abroad they go somewhere else where
they'll actually be paid half decently
and they won't be run ragged all the
time but then you've got like so many
other things just like jobs it's about
rent or housing or social services it's
about literally and then then you look
at this the this the actual state of the
Cities because no one's taking care of
where they live because the social
fabric is kind of constantly under
attack by the addition of new people
everyone just lets everything fall into
disrepair and so you walk through the
high streets and then you can see the
quality of the buildings it's they're
falling apart cuz they're not being
upkept and then you look at the actual
High streets themselves they're all
boarded up just boarded up shops when
often what they'll do is they'll
wallpaper on a picture of an active shop
so it's like yeah this used to be a High
Street oh that's creepy yeah because and
then that's not the fault of necessarily
immigration or anything like that but
then you get lots of foreign shops
springing up in the town centers where
the immigrants live and so where I live
this has happened in the last three
years four years like just before the
covid pandemic this was a relatively
normal English town but immigration
keeps going and now somewh like a
quarter of the town is foreign born and
it's really noticeable in the town
center and I work in the Town Center so
I'm going and like it's just every day
it's just it's like being in the bizarre
of Baghdad like it's not any if if it
was a people from somewhere you know you
could at least be like right okay that's
predictable you know I can get to know
the culture I could Poss possibly learn
some of the language I could learn the
habits I could make some friends in that
culture but it's not like that because
these people are from literally
everywhere in the world and they don't
know each other they don't share a
common culture or a common Heritage or
aurr language or current religion and so
it's just people like this sort of nomad
mass
of of humanity that's just wandering
around a small well it's not small
actually it's quite a large town in
Wilshire and it's just like what are you
doing here you you know you you can't
possibly have known when you were living
50,000 mil away that my town even
existed before you arrived I don't
believe you knew that this place existed
before you got to the UK how did you
arrive here you know but uh but anyway
so yeah things are things are degrading
and people feel alienated I actually
walked past a friend of mine this is
another thing that really bothers me is
I've I've lived in this town for 25
years and my family is from from one of
the sort of suburbs of this
town
and I I had loads of friends here and
whenever I walk through the town center
i' I'd you know bumpers two or three
people on there even though there's like
250,000 people in the area of Swindon
where I live but it was it had a kind of
small town Vibe because it wasn't the
city and so everyone kind of knew
everyone else so you'd have recognized
them from hanging out with someone else
whatever and so i' walk through the town
I bumped to friends and family and stuff
but that just never happens anymore and
I bumped into an old friend of mine and
we were just standing in the middle of
the the shopping center in the town
surrounded by just people from all over
the world and he's like mate I feel like
a stranger in my own land he's been here
his whole life and he feels totally
alienated from the town he's been born
and raised in that's how quickly this
has happened and this is what's happened
to these people and to me and it's just
it's not fair you know it's not fair to
do this to these
people that's wild I I feel like Toronto
Toronto was always kind of a Melting Pot
of people and but they were all kind of
Canadian right so they like they'd
immigrate but they were all Canadian
like they they there was it was a
Melting Pot but it was nice um and I
left Canada a couple years ago when the
co didn't stop there when they shut down
everything and like wrecked downtown I
was like okay this is heading in bad
Direction I'm going to go to America
that seems to be you know there's
America crazy but there's at least
pockets in America that aren't crazy and
in Canada I couldn't find that anymore
it boggles my mind that government
officials didn't see any issues you know
like they must have at least foreseen
the Health Care System having issues
you'd think if you had that job you'd be
like hey this seems like immigration is
great let's get these people in but
let's definitely make sure we have
health care for everyone who still lives
there and is going to come like how do
you miss
that it seems important doesn't it a
little bit seems important and pensions
as well just like one of the reasons
that the brti government brings in so
many foreigners is because they think
well we need people to pay for pensions
it's like they get old too like you know
they don't stay young forever they also
get old and draw a pension and so it's a
pyramid scheme effectively to try and
keep the pensions up um but I I say in
Canada at least I mean like you say they
they felt canadi because I guess
Canada's had a lot of immigration for a
long time right Britain's never had
immigration like 1948 49 something like
that was the very first time we really
had immigration to this country and even
then it was about four or 500 people
like four or 500 people and so for most
of the 20th century Britain was just a
British country it was just the native
population of Britain that lived here
and then towards the end in the in the
90s the governments decided we're just
going to open up the borders completely
and now a quarter of England is foreign
born and it's just like okay but we're
not prepared for this like we don't have
like in America it's fine because
they've got an ideology for it right
they're like oh you you've got the
American dream we have americanism we
can we can Define in like five points
what it is to be an American and so you
have a very clear set of instructions on
what you're supposed to do as an
immigrant to America to fit in with
Americans we don't have anything like
that we're nothing like that we're an
old world country we're an ancient
country we're a thousand years old you
know we're not prepared for this and so
it's just like there there and so
basically you get what in America you
call white flight uh we don't really
call it that over here but that's what's
happening um but it's
happening without it's happening really
fast and
it's it's allowing the cities of England
to become non-english so like London is
37% English luton's 33% I think
leicester's about 34% birmingham's sort
of like 40 45% English and this just
changes the character of these places
it's not that the people in them are bad
or anything like that they're not bad
people you know thank God otherwise it
you
pandemonium but it's something that
nobody asked for you know there was
never a vote in this country shall we
have millions of people come and live
here this is just something the
politicians have been doing to us for 25
years and no one knows why and for some
reason they won't make it stop I mean
the the Home Secretary at the moment was
a woman called swell braveman who's an
Indian woman who was like we need to
stop immigration this is crazy we're
destroying our country for some reason
she herself is an immigrant but it's not
an irrational thing to say she's
completely correct and I know loads of
people who are themselves immigrants
were like yeah you can't just let the
whole world in or else she can have own
everything and she got fired by the
conservative prime minister who is also
an Indian but not because it was like
racist or something it was because do
the Press just start flapping their gums
and oh no there's a there's a there's a
furor in the Press now it's like but
what she's right everyone knows she's
right you know there's she's currently
getting a huge amount of support for
being right because she's like the only
person in the government who's prepared
to tell the truth and it's it's just
this weird unmentionable thing but like
we're not uh a new country we're not a a
new world country we're not a social
contract country you we're a country
that is based on Ancient Traditions
based on an ancient population I mean
there there are people in Britain there
was in in cheddar Gorge right they found
the skeleton of a man that dated back
about 9,000 years to the Ice Age and so
they started DNA testing people in the
local area and two miles away they found
his direct descendant he was a history
teacher two miles away 9,000 years of
time his descendants living there so
that that should tell you how ancient
this place is is and so it's just
bizarre to me that we're prepared to
just treat it like it's some sort of
undiscovered land you know the
government's prepared to just act as if
this is a new frontier we need to bring
as many people as we can it's not the
case sorry I know I'm going on but it's
it's the primary issue in my country
yeah and I like I'd forgotten about that
that's like it's obvious once you say it
but because it Britain is compared to
like the us or Canada in terms of
immigration it's true Canada is really
new and everybody there was immigrant
like all my grandparents yeah were you
know weren't born my great-grandparents
anyway weren't born in Canada and then
it's same with the US I like attract
back relatives to something like the
1600s so like early but that was the
beginning right it wasn't it wasn't
older than that yeah that does and so
then we have had hundreds of years to
kind
of figure out how to include immigrants
because everybody was an immigrant to
begin with that's definitely different
than Britain and your countries also
massive yes very England is actually
really tiny like it's actually a really
small and really densely it's it's
something like the fifth most densely
populated place on the earth you know
it's it's really small from a land scale
uh I mean genuinely like pull up a map
and put like you'll probably be able to
find a map that someone's ins supposed
England into it's probably smaller than
New England you know it's it's really
actually very small uh and it's also
very old and so but we're being treated
like with the American frontier by our
own governments and it's just ruining
everything that we've got and and again
it's not the immigrants are bad people
or anything like that and it's not we
can never have any immigrants or that
none of them should live here it's just
we take a million a year that's mad that
for that amount of space that's mad it's
it's yeah so anyway that's that's the
problem with England at the moment it's
falling apart so do you think okay so
two questions I feel like the same kind
of thing happened uh in Paris right
didn't Paris have massive immigration
and then Paris started to not look like
Paris yep so that um yeah I went there a
couple years ago I was like oh this is
really Multicultural this is more I was
expecting French people yeah not not
it's the same in uh a lot of parts of
London in central London there are still
a lot of English people because it's
where the fancy stuff happens but you
are I I went through Paris a few years
ago and it was just I mean yeah could
have been in the Middle East you know
do you think do you think do you think
you're doomed as as a country or do you
think things are going to reach a point
where everybody recognizes there's an
issue and things are going to turn
around to be honest with you everyone
recognizes that there's an issue already
she already at that point oh yeah uh
consistently the British public has been
60% plus against immigration not not
like you know like you maybe no no no we
want less immigration and that's been
for decades uh for some reason the
politicians just don't care and for some
reason the British public only vote for
left or right they you know the blue or
red uh for some reason they won't vote
for a third alternative that will
actually do something about it so I I
mean doomed is a strong word that I
probably wouldn't use
because we've we're a very old country
things have been worse right there there
was a time in our history when the
Vikings owned
there used to be Seven Kingdoms in
England the Vikings conquered all but
one and that one Kingdom went on to
reconquer all of England wow that was
Alfred the Great um so it's it's been
worse it's been way worse um but it's
not looking good the problem is not that
things are unsalvageable the problem is
we're on a set of rails and there's no
light at the end of the tunnel and we
are just going to keep going down these
rails so things about now in 50 years
time they're going to be way worse then
50 years after that it doesn't really
bear thinking
about
yeah this at any time did the Vikings
stick around like is there a subset of
the populations there are Vikings or did
they get kicked out or killed I
guess both all three actually um so you
initially um Alfred uh reconquered about
half of England and his Grand son went
on to conquer the rest uh which kicked
out all the Viking rulers um but there
were still populations of Danes living
here and then a chap called eel red the
unready uh conducted a kind of Rwanda
style Massacre of Danes in England uh
this was in about the N 900s you know so
this is the sort of thing people did in
the 900s I mean don't don't feel don't
feel bad for the Vikings right they had
come over as genocidal rapists and
pillagers right okay so you know they
they settle the area by killing the
people in the area don't feel bad for
these guys you know and they did this
all over Europe and in the Mediterranean
and in Russia and you know they weren't
good guys don't feel bad for them but
this then backfired and they a lot of
history happens but basically the there
is a I can't remember what the
proportion is but it's probably like 10
or 15% of if you were to DNA sequence
the English you'd find it was Danish uh
genes um and then about half kill IC and
about third Anglo sax or 40% Anglo-Saxon
um so the English are very much a sort
Mongol race you know um and the Dan
definitely did contribute to it but um
but that took a thousand years you know
it's it's a very long long time and we
kind of made it happen you know we we
had Kings who were going to do it by the
sword um we don't have a government
who's prepared to do anything like that
these days and probably for the
better probably probably
yeah I I feel like there's so many wars
recently that I you think when you're
growing up oh this is stuff that
happened back in the uh you know
hundreds of years ago this doesn't
happen anymore and I feel like there's
more and more events happening now that
like oh people are still people like we
have these rules in society and you're
like well our society is more advanced
it doesn't do things like this anymore
um and that seems to not be true at
all yeah this is um this is liberalism
uh telling
us fairy tales I would say uh liberalism
is kind of like a magical spell it kind
of casts itself over your mind and I was
a liberal for many years like
consciously a liberal and then I just
started reading through all of the sort
of canonical texts of liberalism and
comparing them to what had happened and
to other philosophies and I realize that
it's just really well-meaning but it's
wrong um it begins with the idea of a
kind of universal human a sort of Proto
you know Universal person who's running
around on his own in the woods and one
day he bumps into another person and
they don't really care about each other
because they're just getting pine cones
and acorns and stuff fruit from the
woods but one day for some reason they
decide hey should we form a government
and a society and they're like yeah
that's great and that never happened
that's just a total fancy but that's
what liberalism believed uh and that's
the Bedrock of liberalism and that's
what actually trying to get us back to
the the concept of Rights even in the
sort of classical liberal thing is based
on the idea of what can a man do when
he's alone in the woods you know he can
speak he can own Weaponry he can own
property he can get his own food he can
dispose of his own property if there was
a market in his own way that's that's
what liberalism's trying to get back to
is the idea of the atomized man in the
woods but that's just never been the
case and so right liberalism is trying
to bring about a kind of fiction and so
it it it's trying to create these kind
of universal men who are just the sum of
this very sort of narrow Corridor of
Rights and saying right all humans have
these rights and in a way yes but what
that does is when you abstract man away
from society you have to abstract all of
the particulars of society from the man
and so okay he's got a different
religion he's got different language
he's got different culture he has
different interests you know all of
those things have to be taken away to
get the universal man but they're
actually all real things that really
exist in the world and actually really
inform how people act and so actually
there was never a universal man we're
not all the same actually we all
different and we don't really understand
those guys either that's the thing you
really don't understand how those people
think and liberalism makes us arrogant
enough to think well no they'll all just
become like us and we're seeing that's
not true we're seeing that's just not
the case um and so this is why I stopped
being liberal basically
hey popping in again to remind you guys
to try my Afterparty hangover supplement
if you ever drink I find it reduces 80%
of my symptoms or more possibly more and
makes me feel chill and calm the day
after drinking it's actually crazy we
have a 30-day money back guarantee so
give it a shot please for your brain
health Fuller health.com code MP for 15%
off and if you try it please leave a
review I do read all of them I don't
there's a comparable product out there
the vitamin electrolyte mixtures just
don't work so if you've tried some
hangover supplements and you're like
they're a scam I promise this one's not
give it a shot you can read about how it
works on the website again that's Fuller
health.com code MP for 15% off great
stocking stuffers too enjoy the rest of
the
episode I feel like I believed that
until I
was until I was exposed to people more I
I literally thought people were just
like me I until I was I don't know 26
and I started traveling and I went to
Eastern Europe for quite a long time and
wow are Eastern Europeans different than
westerners it's C I was I was blown away
at how different the belief system and
how different the belief system is and
how that changes things and I it felt a
lot more tribal there and Canada is like
what's Canada it's it's not really tribe
I it's just a bunch of like people I'm
I'm not even sure what Canada is but wow
are there other places tribal well the
thing is
like what we think of as normal is our
tribe that's the thing but we've
conditioned ourselves to not see it as
our tribe um but other places outside of
us do see this as our tribe they see
this as our sort of like liberalism is
kind of like sharan law for the english-
speaking world like we come and we
insist on your human rights we insist on
these things but they are like okay well
give me a house if you want you know but
I don't believe in Anglo Sharia like got
you know I'm gonna go home and I'm gonna
be just as tribal as I was in my own
tribe in the way that you kind of are in
your tribe and you know you're you're
imposing this on us but like we don't
believe it in the same way as a bunch of
musl you know jihadists were to impose
Sharia on me I'd be like okay but I
don't believe it I just don't want to
get my head cut off or you know then
like I don't want to go to jail for
violating your human rights or whatever
right they don't believe it U but I mean
some do don't get me wrong but like a
lot don't and that when you when you
take it to other societies it's just a
total failure you know I mean Iraq would
be the primary example they just don't
think like us we just can't do it
Afghanistan is another great example
like oh we're going to set up a liberal
democracy in Afghanistan it's like
you're mad you you don't know these
people if you think that's going to work
and the second America pulls out the
whole thing like Imp in a vacuum so you
know it's we do not understand them and
we're so arrogant as to think that oh
we've got liberalism we've got all the
answers to everything so we don't really
have any answers to any of these things
and the the when you were saying about
wars like that's the that's the the
thing about liberalism it believes it
can bring us to the end of history and
fr Francis fukiyama wrote the book you
know the end of History oh we we've got
past Wars what we're going to do is now
just be individual free agents you know
the liberal dream roaming about in the
forest but in society haven't we figured
all this out it's like the rest of the
world hasn't got the memo actually you
know the rest of the world's still like
old world so um so yeah that's how I
stopped being a liberal
basically so do you think a more
accurate representation rather than
individualism is that generally speaking
people are tribal and people should
understand that individualism is a tribe
that's the thing um and I think that's
the we fail to see that about ourselves
um it's the English speaking world
that's individualist you know and we
have
encouraged uh say the French and the
Germans to try and adopt that as well
but the problem is they don't really
have the same sort of cultural
institutions that the English speaking
world have and so when we in the
anglosphere look over at them you know
what they doing they're doing it wrong
of course they're doing it wrong because
really liberalism is the formalization
of just the political traditions of the
english- speaking world you know the ev
Everything inter meshes together like
the common law is interwoven with the
concepts that build up liberalism like
habus Corpus like free speech like um
personal sovereignty you know all of
these are like English political
Concepts that of course got spread
around with the British Empire but also
got enviously looked upon by the sort of
ideologists in the enlightenment
and the French specifically you've got
plenty of people like voler Russo um
you've got a couple of others I can't
remember the names of them because
they're weird French names but they they
expressly say like the guy who coined
the term
ideology
Antoine LEF or something like that I
think his name is he expressly cites
Thomas Hobbs and John Lock as his
Inspirations for this they they're
consciously looking to the rights of
Englishmen because England was a
relatively free and and fair place and
this is why
every political revolutionary goes to
London they all go to London like Marx
Russo the fascist like when when they're
exiled from somewhere they go to London
because that's safe we're not just going
to persecute them because we have a kind
of ancient political settlement that
kind of works for everyone and that is
what becomes formulated into liberalism
and it works in America which is the
sort of preeminent liberal project
because it was fundamentally like
founding Anglo stock you know English
stock and so really all you're doing
there is you're like telling people this
is what you believe isn't it and they go
yeah that is what we believe it's like
great well we're going to have these
rules it's like okay but that's what we
were doing anyway I guess we'll write
them down and we'll have a full
Constitution it's okay great everyone
agrees because you already believe these
things but when you take that somewhere
else like South America for example
which is of course all Spanish speaking
or Portuguese um you get massively
corrupt
democracies in which um no one in the
English speaking world would recog as
free countries uh and so it's just like
okay well that didn't work why didn't
that work well because it requires
essentially and uh the rouso I don't
like very much but he was right on this
it doesn't really matter what the
Constitution is it has to be it doesn't
matter what's written it has to be
inscribed on the hearts of the people
and so what he means it has to be
genuinely felt it has to be a lived
experience dare I say it uh for the
people of that country and you only get
that when you're born and raised in an
authentic tradition that everyone around
you is doing and has been doing for you
know for generations and you can't just
impose
that well yeah and I I suppose maybe
part of the reason we've seen such
Kickback at least in Canada was because
they started imposing laws that people
didn't agree with and then there was an
up an uproar right you know we wrote
down all these laws everybody agrees
with we haven't had issues so far here's
a new one we'd like to impose on you
guys and then like chaos and hell in
Sue sa
truckers yeah agreed so okay I checked
out your YouTube and you're like you're
not on YouTube and so why is it like not
I mean you're you've got a massive
Channel on YouTube but the your uploads
are elsewhere has YouTube been a problem
for you well they demonetized my channel
and so I thought well I won't bother and
so we we created a website called Lotus
seats.com but we do have a YouTube
channel called the podcast of the lot
seaters so actually we upload lots of
stuff there rather than on my channel um
really I'm I'm kind of doing out
spite because I don't like we we
broadcast the website so that's you know
where the labor goes because people
subscribe to the website for five or a
month and that's how we pay for the
bills you know because obviously YouTube
won't last monetized and so we do put
Clips up on YouTube Just because you
know YouTube's a big platform yeah kind
of got to use it but it's not the
primary one that we put our effort into
just because I it's I'm I'm just kind of
resentful I don't think I'm actually
terribly politically radical and YouTube
just like no you have to be demonetized
okay fine you know fine why did you get
de so you got permanently demonetized
yeah yeah yeah because I made a joke
about a politician and it was like okay
not politicians I mean that's a sign of
a free Society it was a very rude joke
I'm not gonna say it wasn't but like
I mean politicians used to be fair game
that's you know in in my country anyway
I mean maybe not in California where
YouTube was making their judgments but
uh wow okay that's wild I know I'm still
on YouTube I just put anything that's
like too too
controversial on Rumble that very wise
very I'm not gonna fight that monster oh
you did yeah yeah I just started my
little Rumble channel it's only got like
3,000 subscribers or whatever but like
it's just nice to be able to because
what I used to do with my YouTube
channel after even after we started loot
seaters like I used to just sit in front
of my camera and just do a stream and
just talk for an hour you know just to
just to be in contact with the people
who are subscribing to me but YouTube is
just such a belligerent platform I don't
want to do it whereas Rumble is such a
welcoming platform I'm like yeah okay
I'll use you you know because you're
actually you seem to be invested in me
as a content creator why would I give my
labor to a platform I actually seems to
kind of hate me and all my friends as
well like you know literally everyone
I'm friends with on the internet
YouTube's like oh that's a bad person
demonetized get the gold icon or get
Shadow banned and it's just
like can't we just have our thoughts you
know oh I I don't know if you know about
this so my mom just got a strike on her
Channel she's got a small Channel she
does a podcast she has like 50,000
subscribers and she had this like
90-year-old Holocaust Survivor on and
the Holocaust Survivor said covid was a
fraud you know and so that that was up
on YouTube and she got a strike on her
Channel and they mandated um social
media training so it wasn't just a
strike and you remove the video she has
to do some sort of training I've never
heard of that it's a new thing that
YouTube have brought in uh I'm actually
super careful about gang strikes so uh
you know in the office as a team we keep
very careful track of what the YouTube
guy dos like because people don't
realize YouTube has editorial guidelines
like as I understand it the law in the
United States that prevents YouTube from
being sued uh by people instead of the
person who uploads something say
defamatory or liess is because they say
well we're just a platform we're just
here to host content and therefore the
person who puts the content up is the
person responsible for the editorial
decision and therefore they're the ones
you sue we get out scot-free and that's
I can't remember that is like section
280 or something know what it's called
right but um but YouTube now has
editorial policies so it's okay well
could someone please take that to court
so the Court's like no you you make
editorial decisions on a whole manner of
things uh you can sue YouTube now and
then I tell you what they will stop with
their editorial guidelines very very
quickly when it becomes apparent that
actually people can sue YouTube because
they're not adhering to the standard
that allows them to act without being
sued so I mean I think that would go
very far in an American core I'm not an
expert but like it seems it seems like a
fruitful thing for because I know I know
there's sort of like YouTube lawyers
there's a culture of YouTube lawyers I
don't know why none of them are sort of
like hey why don't we push that you know
we see that where that goes you know
because they they don't have to pay for
a lawyer you know so yeah yeah exactly
okay so you're just careful with YouTube
Stripes that seems like a good idea I
that I told my mom that too I was like
don't fight it you can't fight it you
can't like write something and they're
going to change their guidelines just
you have to be careful about what
content you put on YouTube to play the
system you're living under absolute
tyranny when it comes to YouTube you've
got no right of appeal you know if they
give you an appeal you're very lucky and
if they deny it there's nothing you can
do about it there's no Arbiter you're
just under the Tyranny so you've got to
be smart and just accept okay these are
the rules I'll have to play by them yeah
agreed unfortunately because because I
guess people are told you know fight
back against other things but YouTube's
kind of this giant Behemoth that maybe
something else will pop along in the
future but it's pretty big well and
there's nothing you can do either really
you know you've got you've got no
leverage over YouTube so it's very
frustrating so you said well I suppose
okay so identifying as a traditionalist
I don't know if you would use the words
identify as a traditionalist or not but
that doesn't count as an
ideology no no because I I don't have a
pre-formatted
image of what the world should look like
um I can't tell you what you know there
isn't just a list of things that we can
do to create the perfect traditional
Society um a tradition isn't something
that any one person's got control over
it's the combined result of the actions
of many people over a great deal of time
or working independently of each other
but in the same
direction uh and so Traditions are kind
of like um kind of like a a
civilizational trial and error and they
build up their own ways of doing things
and they build up their own character is
based on the sort of people who are
doing it so for example I mean a great
example in Britain is the coronation of
the king or the queen uh you recognize
that as being obviously British but lots
of other countries have kings and queens
and have coronation ceremonies it's just
that they're different in character to
our one uh even though they are kind of
in the same oldold so but if you had an
ideology
it could be that they could all be
exactly the same you know so these are
products of kind of they're like they're
almost organic you know I mean like this
s thing that grows and changes like a
tree and that's kind of what a tradition
is like it's kind of like a river
maybe I like that how did you manage to
switch your views from more liberal to
being more open like how did you did did
you grieve that process like was there a
really did cuz I've had some of my
belief systems change when I started
recognizing that what I believed was a
total lie and I feel like it really
turned my life upside down right I
didn't know what to believe I was like
is anything true is anything I believed
true what else do what else am I
believing that's a lie I don't want to
believe anything that's a lie like did
you have that kind of
switch it wasn't overnights um it was a
gradual process but it was it was more
about being
in the scope of what I believed um yeah
because the problem with ideology is
because it's abstract it becomes
Universal and so you say well every
person should live like this because I
think that's good and maybe for you that
would be good and maybe for a small
number of people or maybe even a town or
a city or even a country that might be
good but you can't help but expand it to
all mankind because it begins on you
personally and in the sort of liberal
framework that most ideologies reside
like libertarianism is a form of
liberalism socialism is an outgrowth of
liberalism you know they they they rest
on the same philosophical foundations
and so you can't help but believe your
constituency is All Mankind and that
gives you a really big and Broad and
insane conception of the world right
that's kind of mad that you're like yeah
no I'm in my head I'm legislating for
all Humanity not just now but all
through the past and all into the future
for all of time my idea is like the idea
it's like that's wild man like I don't
know you know I'm still struggling with
what time my kids have got to go to bed
really you know so like it was about
being a bit more humble with the scope
of what I thought was right and wrong
and locating it to my own country which
at least I have direct experience of and
I can look at the things we do even if
they're a bit irrational and a bit kooky
as you know British politics I mean like
why why are we shouting at each other in
the House of Commons because we've
always shouted each other in the House
of Commons it must have a function even
if I don't know what it is and yeah it's
kind of embarrassing when a foreigner is
like oh my God is that how you conduct
politics like yes kind of it is
embarrassing but but it must work in
some way and so I'll accept it and you
know that's something we do and it's a
part of the wider tapestry and this
another thing like there are connections
between things that you don't
see you don't even know we're there
until they're gone and it's only at that
point that it's too late to bring them
back uh to restore the thing that was
doing something that you didn't realize
it was doing and this is the problem
with ideology as well is it it
highlights some linkages and makes
invisible the rest and so you know the
like this the shouting in the houses
houses of Parliament might have a real
sort of calming effect on people
politically or something like that I
don't know you know but it it probably
does something that I'm just not aware
of and so it's this kind of humbling of
okay I don't have all the answers
actually and maybe maybe taking smaller
steps in a local position like much like
the sort of thing a dad advises actually
is like look maybe if I just start with
what's directly around me and make small
changes incrementally over time might be
better than Revolution you know might be
better than trying to change everything
for all Humanity for all of time and see
my life has got immeasurably better on a
just immediate personal level uh and for
my family and my friends my business um
since I've had that kind of conscious
understanding of this is the way forward
you know that's it's definitely much
better for the individual person I think
well I'm not going to be able to s a
Libertarian after this
podcast morally so you've taken that it
well if it helps like think I just don't
know how to frame it what's it what's it
called I'm not sure so I I have
libertarian instincts right I don't like
the state getting involved with stuff I
don't like people I don't like the fact
that I can't be armed right it really
bothers me but there's on a genuine
emotional level I'm actually bothered
that I can't really own a sidearm you
know I could get a shotgun or a hunting
rifle or something but hey the state
would be like why do you want it and I'd
be like I want to go duck hunting I want
to go pigeon shooting you're not allowed
it for home defense and I'm like I'm I
want to have a gun on my hip so I can
shoot someone who attacks me actually
that's why I want the gun you know but I
can't say that you know now I've said on
the podcast I'll probably never get a
license for again um but like so like
having having these sort of instincts is
totally fine and and from the sort of
leftwing position like I want to help
people you know that's the the the
Socialist impulse I think genuinely
comes from a position of a desire to
help humanity and the people around them
right it's just they don't really know
how to do it so they've and and the
Socialists come prepackaged with a whole
ream of ideology that tells them look
believe these things Advocate this
you're a good person and you're going to
win and that's seductive it's hard not
to be it's hard not to be taken Along by
that you know and so I think rather than
being committed to the ideology it's
worth thinking of yourself as just being
inclined having the the moral sentiment
towards the thing that underpins the
ideology it's Freedom whether it's
cooperation whether it's care for others
and that's that's you know that's at
least you not relinquishing the sort of
core of yourself but also managing to
sort of get the sludge of the ideology
off yourself and because that was the
thing coming out of liberalism really
felt like I was coming out of like the
Matrix like you know he's in the Slime
and he's just like H pulls the thing out
of his mouth he's like where the hell am
I I kind of felt like that when I was
coming out of liberalism I think that's
just what ideolog is like it covers you
in a sludge and you need to kind of
scrape it off and be like right okay I
feel genuinely quite wholesome and
decent let's begin from here you
know that I like that that's kind of how
I felt yeah like get it off I was so
angry too when some of my belief systems
fell apart I was just like how could I
have been so stupid yeah like like I was
lied to and that's why I believed these
things but how could I have just
believed these things and for me it
started with the health care system in
Canada thinking and I was quite ill and
trusted the healthare system and doctors
and things and then when that fell apart
it's just everything fell apart it was
like well what other figure of authority
is telling me that they're there for my
benefit and I trust them when I
shouldn't and so that makes you like you
get hit a couple of times with those
belief systems falling apart and
hopefully it makes you humble about not
not knowing what else you have
wrong yes it's quite mad isn't it I
can't get over the Canadian Healthcare
System man like oh and you should hear
Canadians talk about it they're like
we've got the best healthare system in
the world it's free like there's a
reason it's
free well you should hear people talk
about the NHS the the NHS is our God uh
we England isn't a country with a Health
Service the Health Service is the health
service with a country uh we live to
serve the NHS if without the NHS
everyone in England dies you see uh and
we we praise and worship the NHS like
literally like some sort of pmic Idol
where we have to make sacrifices to it
um and it's it's mental it's just mental
and you know I mean don't wrong I like
having a public Healthcare option I like
I like the fact that option yeah yeah um
I don't want to worship it as a god
actually weirdly enough but um I I can't
stand the maid thing in your in your
country though man oh I I did a an
opposing views uh podcast so I had one
person who was Pro made on and one
person who was anti-m made he was from
uh America but the promade woman who it
was a doctor who spends her time um you
know killing
people is what she's doing uh it was
really quite disturbing it's bad go tell
tell me a bit well she she
was she was just as creepy as you
thought somebody would be she was like
star ccure she was a caricature of who I
hope to get on to talk about ma but it's
really you know under the guise of
compassion you know and I so I was
asking questions like well what happens
if people are young and mentally
ill and um and now you can still apply
for maid when you're young and mentally
ill in Canada was like well you can get
very suicidal and very depressed and not
have that be your entire life yeah right
it's just and that like I struggled with
a quite severe depression and and pain
from surgeries and things and not being
able to get health care fast enough
because good old Canada and there were
points where I was suicidal and there
were points when well it was it's just
having that as an option is so dangerous
for people who already feel like they're
a burden on society and they're burden
on their family and they don't know if
they're going to get better it's just I
can't believe that's happening under
guys of compassion it's
so dystopian it's so
disturbing and it's like 10,000 people a
year as well isn't it yeah for now yeah
yeah it's it's like six I saw a stat it
was the six biggest killer in Canada is
the government and I again I don't want
to get all libertarian about it but that
feels a bit
wrong I and I've seen some like accounts
where you know people who are just
mildly inconvenienced by something get a
letter through have you considered
killing
yourself yes no no I haven't you know I
wanted there was this one woman who
wanted a stairlift
installed my mom interviewed her oh
really that was right yeah and it was
you considered just shooting let no you
you monsters
like it's mad it's absolutely mad yeah
it's mad have you considered killing
yourself that's I just want to Stair
Lift the stairs are really for me yeah
I'm just feeling a bit down today you
know could I get some prescriptions to
make myself feel a little better no but
we could euthanize you so great yeah the
thing is as well what one thing that
really bothers me about this is the way
that we look at this Through The Eyes of
the individual alone
because I mean I can concede that there
could be some circumstances where
someone who's got like terminal cancer
and there is unbelievable pain all the
time and it's like look we can cuz I
mean this this happened to my nan when
she passed away over covid she didn't
pass away from covid she had cancer and
so she was basically just morphed up for
like the last week or two of her life
and yeah I mean I saw her before she
went but she was just unconscious and
imp pain she you know unconscious and
groaning and it was just like okay this
is terrible oh um yeah and so it like
you know in a circumstance like that
okay yeah I can totally see the validity
of a 91y old woman um being spared that
kind of suffering right but there's a
difference between that and someone
who's 27 and depressed and because
they've just you know they've had a
series of just reverses in their life
you know they broke up their boyfriend
they lost their job oh they're getting
kicked out their apartment okay I may as
well just go into the suicide Booth and
etherize myself like there it's awful
and the thing the thing that really
bothers me is like people aren't just
alone people aren't just individuals
right you're connected whatever everyone
is born into a web of relationships with
their brothers their sisters their
mothers their cousins their aunts their
fathers their uncles their grandparents
their neighbors their friends you know
they like friends to be in the future
you know like all of these things all
exist in you and are connected to you
with like these sort of you know have
you ever seen the film Donnie Darko
right oh yeah you know the weird beam
thing that comes out of his chest that's
how I kind of view what a relationship
is these days so he connects two people
and this weird beam and if if the the
more you love that person the thicker
and brighter that beam is and the less
the more it Withers away right and if
you think of like a person as being
situated in reality with these things
connecting to everyone they know in some
degree and then they've got one only
everyone else they know the suddenly you
see there's this great shining web that
connects everyone it's like someone
killing
themselves ruins the connection that
they have with everyone it and it's this
real sharp pain that everyone feels like
my uncle commited suicide a few years
ago and man my cousins have not been the
same sense it's been unbelievably
painful for them I it breaks my heart
you know it's just you don't realize the
damage you do when you do that you know
you're you're not the only person who
matters here actually and the but again
it's a kind of consequence of the spell
of liberalism it's like well it's your
choice it's you it's like okay you're
you're feeling a bit m
but your mom is going to feel so much
worse for what you know for you and and
and it's so shortsighted in the near
future things will get better like it's
not going to be like this forever you
know yeah no horrible thing about mental
illness too is when you're in it it
feels like it's going to be there
forever it really does
and and you shouldn't have I don't think
you should have that option and it's
funny because so the guy I talked to who
was based in the US he said well there
are states that have had you know gentle
ways of dying so like assisted death for
decades and decades but it's set for
these people that are like like you
described they're really old and really
sick and it's just like come on they
don't need to suffer this out like we
already know what's going to happen in
the end but no one talked about it
because that was okay and then yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's pretty bad but no that's
screwed though I think for a while yeah
I think so too I've I've got a bunch of
Canadian friends and they all say the
same there exactly what you're saying
you know it's just like all of the
problems but this this the thing I was
thinking that what you just said like
they we you know they already do this
for the old folks who are very old and
suffering and dying but no one cares no
one talks about it why not and I think
it's genuinely something to do with the
fact that people live their lives and
stories right that your your life is
your story and you think of it as your
story
and every story has acts and of course
when you're like 80 years old you're in
the Final Act of your story and there's
only one conclusion to the Final Act of
the story and that's for you to pass on
and so it's normal and natural for that
to happen you know and so no one's
surprised about there's nothing
offensive about it it's inevitable
actually and you know I'm not saying we
should look for to it but like we
shouldn't like I'm not bothered about
growing old like this really weird like
I'm not I am 44 and I'm actually happier
now than I've ever been in my life and I
don't see myself getting less happy you
know and I'm not bothered by my age I'm
not bothered by going gray like I'm
actually kind of enjoying it you know it
g it gives you you know I've arrived in
a different stage of life where actually
I feel like I've got a lot of stuff
figured out actually and I can see the
young people around me who don't have
these things figured out and I can see
them making the same mistakes I made and
I can actually give them some pertinent
advice and so like it's not bad to move
into the new phases of your story and
for some reason and again it's
liberalism is the spell here because it
thinks of us as kind of self-created
humans that have always existed and all
exist always exist at year zero it's
like no actually we're a long tale and
the longer the story goes on for the
more Rich it becomes and the more
worthwhile it is hearing for other
people you know and so we it's just a
totally different way of seeing
ourselves our civilization our own lives
you know the purpose we have with the
people around us but it's just I just
feel so much better and I'm not like on
social justice Crusades to try and
eliminate you know hardship or anything
I'm just watching everyone around me do
well and it's good to be a part of it
yeah that's so nice that would be nice
for people to hear I I think I think the
same thing I like the younger I was the
harder the harder life was and that was
partly from being ill but it was also
partly
from I don't I'm not sure although what
I can say is the 30s is significantly
better than the 20s which isn't
something I thought I would say yeah
it's totally true because you don't know
anything you know you're just
inexperienced in your 20s and I mean I
remember my 20s and I like had no idea
what I was
doing at all I was totally unored like
you think you
did
I didn't think about it you know I just
like bumbled through each day not really
thinking very hard about the future and
we never encouraged to think about the
future you know there was no nothing
around me that was telling me by the way
have you've been planning for like 10
years time 20 years time and so by the
time I was in my mid-30s I hadn't
achieved anything really I didn't really
I didn't think about it and then I
started like a YouTube channels cuz I
was pissed off with a few things and
suddenly you know 10 years later I've
got this massive YouTube channel and
I've got business and stuff like that
but so I like kind of locked into being
successful but had that not happened I
don't even know how I would have become
successful I you know I would I may may
well have not you know and so I I really
wish I'd been better advised when I was
young to think and have a a more
long-term view of my own story you know
where you know to view it as like you
know you need to take certain steps now
to arrive at a certain place then so
actually crack on you know trust me you
know you will think it's worth it you
know I think I'm really fortunate to
have had my dad as my dad because
long-term planning long-term planning
was built like I don't even remember I
remember planning longterm when I was in
like grade two really it was just built
in yeah so I always had a 10-year plan
uh now unfortunately like things would
change and then that plan would be
completely fall apart which kind of hurt
but I was I always had a long-term plan
and so I never I never had that and I
didn't realize how rare that was so yeah
I mean my my dad's like a very
conservative guy and so he was always
like you know you need to think ahead
son you know you need to think of this
you need to think of that you need to
work hard but the culture I was submers
in the sort of you know pop culture of
the sort of 90s and the early 2000s the
message was the total reverse you know
is literally don't worry about it
everything will be fine you're in the
end of History basically is what they
were saying uh you can just relax and be
a wasal you know that was essentially
the message that was coming across and
so thinking about it now my dad's good
advice was always totally drowned out by
this cultural messaging and I've I've
always been a pretty self-confident
person with my ability to handle
whatever's in front of me and so I
didn't really listen to him you know so
by the time I got into the my early 30s
I was like oh my God what why why don't
I have the things I expected to have you
know and the the it I mean maybe in your
case it's different s thing but like I
think for most people I think this
cultural you know fluid that we exist
and swim through is really powerful on a
subconscious level I don't think people
really think about it but if we had more
wholesome and positive messaging rather
than
the messaging we get out of TV and the
the music we listen to and if you think
about like just take a second to be
vaguely critical of the music the lyrics
to any music you listen to or the
general message of any film that you
watch and think is that what I teach my
kids you know when I want my kids
thinking that you realize actually the
entire culture is kind of like debed you
know like there's kind of like gross and
um
immediate and it's not very very
conducive to creating a better world
tomorrow and I I think about this a lot
it's just
like what must other people think of us
right because I mean I know that like a
lot of the criticisms of quite Hardline
islamist are we're a disgusting perverse
culture and I'm like well kind of and
here's cardi B's
WAP you know and it's just like yeah
that's kind of
true not I I you know I don't like their
religion I don't respect them as people
I don't want to do what they want to do
but some of their critiques do cut a bit
close to home right
so that's how I kind of felt in Eastern
Europe too with with uh Russian
critiques of America it's like well look
at what you're doing to your kids in
school
yep not sure what I can say about that
yeah I can't can't got us there to be
honest you know
yeah well that was very interesting
thank you so much for taking the time to
talk to me that was fun oh my my
pleasure sorry it felt a lot more
serious than I thought it was going to
be actually like I I F you know I i' you
know seen a few speeches not not not
this um heavy tonely normally and so I
thought we just end up having quite a
fun conversation but then you sort of
like open with questions I like have
been thinking about and couldn't help
but kind of just
just you know big brain dump okay well
here are my thoughts on it and you know
I think they're quite existential and we
need to think about them you know um so
I hope it wasn't too too much or
anything you know no no no not at all
that was way better that was good I
wanted to go I guess I wanted to go deep
that was fun so thank you great um thank
you very much for coming on it's my
pleasure honestly I really I really
appreciate the invite it's really
[Music]
good
oh